this is a production of cornell
university
[Music]
i was six years old when i brought my
first cucumber to my mother
it was withered yellowing and
approximately five or six inches in
length
but the immense pride i felt was
unshaken watching the tendrils from the
cucumber plant curl around the trellis i
provided for it was the first time i was
consciously aware of having a love of
nature
can you believe a 5 000 year old
traditional farming technology
has a place in today's high-tech
greenhouses my name is jonah helmer
and i'm a sophomore at cornell
university majoring in plant sciences
with a concentration in sustainability
and a minor in nutritional sciences by
the year 2050
we're going to need to double the
world's food supply in order to feed our
growing population
my interest in sustainability has led me
to research aquaponics
as a possible solution to this problem
i've worked in research projects that
assess
the difference between hydroponic and
aquaponic growing methods
i'm also the vice president of the
cornell hydroponics club
i hope to use these experiences to build
a career growing sustainable
nutritious and affordable produce and
greenhouses accessible to urban
populations
hi my name is becky stoke and i'm a
student at cornell
i was first on to plant science because
of one of the main issues facing va
society
food insecurity i've long been
interested in plant pathology
and i feel like by studying the genetic
basis of disease resistance in plants
i can then apply that knowledge using
gene editing technology to improve crop
yields and therefore
increase the whole amount of food
available to general public however
i've noticed a huge disconnect between
the public and scientists
people don't know where they're like
where their food is coming from or
anything about the technologies being
used to produce it
this is especially evident when it comes
to gmos a recent survey of consumer
attitudes found that ideas such as
they're injecting toxic hormones into
our foods are still distressingly common
therefore i want to study science
communications and outreach techniques
on top of my plant science education
so that i can be more adequately
prepared to educate the public
throughout my career
i realize there's so much more to
understand about the complex
relationships
between plants and soils and microbes
that live in the soils
and trees and humans hi i'm macy smith
i'm a freshman plant sciences major at
cornell university
i'm from cleveland ohio which is where i
first was interested
in plants i had an internship at
cleveland
tampa gardens and it was there that i
realized
how much i enjoyed working with and
being around plants
last year i had the opportunity to
travel to belize with my science class
which is what solidified my choice to
study plant sciences
there we met a woman named aurora
aurora was called on by her uncle her
village's healer
in their mind community to become the
village's next healer
hi my name is michael morinski and i'm a
freshman here at cornell university
one of the first one of the reasons why
i really love plants is just waking up
in the morning and seeing how much
they've grown since
last day several studies have shown the
benefits of plants on mentals of mental
health
but i also want to examine the multiple
benefits of plants on your physical
state
i want to bring that relationship
between humans and plants to the medical
field and i hope to
attend a medical school post-graduation
the simple activity of helping my family
kind of garden in our backyard
built a long-term connection as a
cornell
student i hope that my hands will look
as old as they are meant to be
hi i'm victoria mock and i'm a current
play of science students here at cornell
also seeking minor in business
i grew up in northern california and so
i'm well aware of scarce resources
involved in agriculture specifically
water in this
case and the challenges they pose on
efficient and healthy crop production
i just recently started learning about
indoor vertical farms but already the
idea of transforming a space where there
is virtually nothing
into somewhere where you can grow crops
efficiently is so appealing to me
mainly because each resource can be
tailored exactly to each plant need
and external factors such as a changing
climate and other difficulties like that
are essentially gone these facilities
are also highly sustainable
because the need for fertilizers and
pesticides is limited
in the future i would love to work for
one of these standard vertical farms
helping to improve their crop crop
quality and health
and while also combating economic
challenges such as input costs
and facility management hey my name is
eddie almanza i'm a freshman at cornell
university pursuing a major in plant
sciences
and a minor in business i'm from trenton
north carolina which is very rural
and very dependent on agriculture since
there were so many agricultural jobs i
began working
on farms and with various crops such as
tobacco
sweet potatoes cucumbers and soybeans
for these crops i mainly just walked
behind a tractor replanting the crop
or walking through a field pulling out
weeds and suckers
eventually i went on to work for a
farmer and him
we grew and harvested the hemp in a
greenhouse and the attention to detail
to the ph temperature and amount of
light needed was
incredibly interesting this led me to
realize that
i wasn't interested in plants just
because i could make money but i was
interested in plants but because
they were so interesting the way they
grew and that we can control the factors
that
determines how they grow hi my name is
leor cole and i'm a freshman at cornell
university
ever since i was little i had a
fascination with plants
and as i grew up i was diagnosed with
celiac disease which only increased that
fascination
i learned that the wheat crop was being
genetically engineered in spain to grow
as a sort of gluten-free weed which
really
piqued my interest so in high school i
started a club plant focused club
and i got involved with research hi my
name is lexi mantija i'm a current plant
science major at cornell and
what attracted me to this major was a
research experience i had in my past
national park which is
45 kilometers south of churchill
manitoba interestingly
churchill has a larger polar bear
population than human population
so this was the first time in my life
that i was
in a place that was largely untouched by
humans it was just miles and miles of
land that had
all this natural life and natural beauty
and it was the first time in my life
that i was exposed
to all the complexities of the
interactions of all these different
forms of life and how they come together
i also learned about what can happen
when when one of these elements becomes
unbalanced
and how this could affect people living
in that environment
hi i'm ben polson one of my earliest
memories is that my dad and i trying to
grow tomato seedling in our backyard
i was only three and he's from the city
so we had no idea what we were doing
the plant died really quickly because we
put it in the shadiest spot possible
after that i was inspired to actually
grow plants correctly
i would read seed packets really
diligently and plan out all my gardens
on graph paper
my gardens got better and better and in
high school i worked at wegmans and a
community
farm where i learned the more industrial
side of agriculture
that inspired me to become a plant
sciences major at cornell university
and i want to focus on horticulture and
more specifically controlled environment
agriculture because i think it would be
great
to provide sustainable fresh produce to
cities
all around the world plants are a vital
part of the medical field from
pharmaceuticals
to their mood boosting abilities
and i hope to study the relationship
better and to learn how to
apply this knowledge towards medical
field to improve health care
and to bring a new perspective into the
field thank you
hi my name is victoria zhang and i am a
plant science major plantings
concentrate
and plant breeding enchantments plants
have been involved in some of my
favorite memories
i remember being a kid helping my dad in
the garden and being so proud when i
picked my first homegrown tomato
ever since then i've always been my
happiest and working with plants but i
never really
got into the scientific aspect of it
until one day two of my functions were
flowering at the same time
and i decided to cross-pollinate them to
make my own hybrid well that failed but
i'm still really glad i tried because it
opened my eyes for the world of plant
breeding and at cornell i realized how
much we rely on it
scientists in the field have to respond
to all different kinds of pressures
from our changing culinary tastes to
our see new trends and ornamental plants
and ultimately
the future of our food supply threatened
by disease and
my name is justin i'm currently a
sophomore here at cornell
ever since i could walk i was completely
captivated by plants
and when i was 10 or 11 i remember i got
my first job is sweeping
the floors of my greenhouse down the
road from where we live and that was
enough to like blow my mind and then
that's how i saved enough money i was
about 13. i built my first greenhouse
and became like a certifiable plant
order that's kind of history
um as my interest grew over the next
five or so years
i decided to come to cornell major in
plant science
um coming here with the best resources
essex offers just kind of like the
natural next step
and for with the rapidly changing
climate
as well advances in plant biology are
exploding in demand so for me personally
concentrating my studies in evolution
and understanding how plants involved in
the past i feel a reliable model for
predicting how they can be best modified
for the future uses of society
thank you hi i'm luke johnson i'm a
freshman studying plant sciences at
cornell
i first got into plants simply by
gardening with my mom
and my dad at home every year i'd ask my
parents to make the garden bigger and
bigger
that's what happened i decided to study
plant science
in college because i think we rely so
heavily on plants
and there's so much potential for what
can be done with them
there's lots of problems facing the
world like climate change population
growth changes in eating habits and
developments and new plant technologies
are really going to be necessary in the
future
and i think it's the plant scientists
that can make that happen
hi my name is hannah rudd and i'm a
freshman studying plant sciences at
cornell's college of agriculture and
life sciences
i grew up in new york city in a
household that really valued hospitality
and bringing people
joy through food but growing up in new
york city i also saw the effects of
food deserts and not having access to
affordable and healthy food
so with a base in plant science as well
as an
understanding of food distribution
public policy and nutrition
i'm really hoping to bring my passion to
tangible change
in urban areas which are places that i
love hi i'm steven espresso and i'm a
plant science major at cornell from el
paso texas
nitrogen and phosphorus are two of the
main components of fertilizer
and currently though mostly
synthetically produced will mine
but every day we excrete millions of
pounds of these nutrients in our yummy
and all it does is go to waste and
pollute our drinking water
if you could divert urine which is just
one percent of all sewage waste
farmers could use this as fertilizer
this would be really beneficial because
it would conserve water
and localize fertilizer production
this has been a production of cornell
university
on the web at cornell.edu